qu'est ce que tu te dis tous les
matins
quand tu me vois dans le
miroir  j'ai toujours voulu une queue
et j'ai essayé plusieurs fois en
chirurgie plastique d'en avoir une attachée mais elles
durent trois ou quatre jours
puis elles tombent que changeriez-
vous en vous si vous aviez la touche magique
je changerais ma personnalité  est la
seule chose
dont je ne suis pas satisfait de moi
-même et j'aimerais ressembler beaucoup plus à
jamie lee curtis n'aimeriez-vous pas être
plus petit que
six pieds et demi oui j'aimerais
être très très petit je le ferais  j'aime être
si petit alors je pourrais me transporter
dans ma poche
et si je m'ennuyais lors d'une réunion je pouvais
simplement aller dormir comment est-il possible qu'un
groupe de diplômés d'oxford et de cambridge
forment monty python
parce que je pense que tu devais  être très
étrange d'entrer ou
d'oxford ou de cambridge au ti  moi que
j'étais là
et que la plupart des meilleures personnes là-bas étaient
complètement folles
et le grand avantage d'être
complètement fou et très bien éduqué est
que tout le monde a peur de toi
qui était le patron euh nous étions tous le
patron à tour de rôle  10 heures j'étais
le patron à 11 heures graham chap était
le patron
à 12 heures michael palin était le patron
terry rejoint son patron à une heure puis
terry gilliam a été dirigé à deux et euh
eric à trois
et puis après cela, nous nous battrions beaucoup,
je ne veux pas dire simplement discuter, je veux dire des combats au poing,
ce n'était pas une bonne équipe avec laquelle travailler,
ce sont toutes les cicatrices,
comment cela a-t-il fonctionné, non,
c'était un désastre total mais
heureusement  nous avons pu trouver
six autres personnes qui nous ressemblaient beaucoup,
qui étaient toutes belges
et elles venaient au studio et faisaient
le show pour nous mais nous les avons payées pour garder
le silence
aussi vous savez Woody Allen a essayé d'entrer
dans le groupe
et  il est souvent venu nous voir avec son
matériel il avait écrit ces sketches  s mais
ils étaient toujours très
déprimants donc nous avons juste dû lui dire qu'il
ne pouvait pas nous rejoindre mais
il est allé à new york et je pense qu'il s'en est
plutôt bien sorti
le fait que cela devenait si
dangereux physiquement que la plupart d'entre nous
devenaient cicatrisés et n'avaient pas l'air
trop bien
devant la caméra, donc on pensait que c'était plus sûr travaillerez-vous à nouveau
sous ce nom ensemble, je pense que
nous
travaillerons ensemble par deux et par trois tout comme
eric idle vient d'être dans
le film baron munchausen de terry gilliam
et je viens de faire
trois jours sur le film de terry jones eric
le viking et michael palin est dans ce
merveilleux nouveau film
fish appelé wanda donc nous travaillons ensemble par
deux et par trois
aussi c'est c'est  difficile maintenant parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont très vieux et plusieurs d'
entre eux sont morts
comment expliquez-vous que vous avez gagné le gros
lot en can
mais pas avec votre meilleur film eh bien cela
nous a coûté beaucoup d'argent
heureusement comme vous connaissez le français  h les
festivals sont les plus faciles à gagner parce que
les jurys sont les plus soudoyés
mais dans ce cas c'était
phénoménalement cher presque aussi
cher que de gagner un prix
pourquoi se demandait-il qu'un film anglais ait autant de
succès aux états-unis
parce que j'étais très  rusé parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis américains
et un flot d'ex-femmes américaines et
cela m'a permis de voir à quel
point les américains sont profondément stupides
et donc j'ai fait un film très très
simple qui ne nécessitait aucune connaissance ou
intelligence
ou tout type de  perception ou perspicacité à
comprendre et
ça a été un énorme succès là-bas qui est ou était
le meilleur
acteur comique sur terre à part moi
je ne pensais pas qu'il y avait de compétition
chaplin était bon quelques fois ce
qui vous fait rire à
chaque fois que vous pensez à  c'est euh vice-
président caille
pourquoi avez-vous arrêté de boire question
pourquoi ai-je arrêté de boire euh parce que j'ai vu
ce que ça a fait à graham chapman
et graham comme vous le savez est un homme très vague
et avant qu'il arrête dr  l'encrage il était
même végétalien
en fait il est euh il a écrit au moment où
il écrit un livre intitulé l'art de
vegas
au moins il pense qu'il peut l'être et si ta
vie devait être vécue à nouveau
euh je le ferais dans le colorado